nearly half of the people who made New
Year's resolutions reportedly want to
lose weight or get in shape US News and
World Report ranks Weight Watchers as
the best weight loss diet the company
has more than 3 million subscribers
online and for meetings the diet assigns
points to food and members are given a
certain number of points to eat per day
last month Weight Watchers introduced
freestyle a program featuring more than
200 foods that count for zero points
Mindy Grossman is president and CEO of
Weight Watchers Mindy welcome morning
and we were just talking about zero
points what what what is zero points
what gets zero cool so freestyle which
is the program that just launched is
literally the most livable simple and
effective program we've had in the
company's history
so there's point values so all 300
calories are not created equal it's a
combination of the nutrients satiating
all of those things so there's a whole
group of foods including all fish
chicken fruits vegetables peas corn that
are zero points and so you build your
point values around the day and it gives
you such freedom to be able to be as
livable as possible and go out and eat
with your family because you're eating
foods that everyone else is you're not
having to eat packaged foods or things
and it has had the most effective weight
loss that we've had in the history of
the company so like the fish is zero but
then if you put butter on it that counts
for correct correct
what are you concerned by saying that
all these foods are zero points that the
calories don't matter because calories
do matter that it that it would
encourage people to overeat well I don't
think anybody ever really over ate
chicken breast right so it also you know
John butter fried chicken it really is
about balance and what we do is really
inspire healthy habits for sustainable
capabilities for people to make the
right choices and that's important
people want to be healthy today if you
think about it people ask me who our
biggest competition is and the reality
is it's people believing they can do
this themselves and so we really want to
be the partner to everyone to give them
the capabilities and the knowledge to be
able to lead healthier better lives look
I've been studying diet and nutrition my
entire life and I the proof is in the
pudding that Weight Watchers works and
to I think it's the healthiest way to
try and lose weight if not one of the
only ways to lose weight you now have DJ
Khaled who is of course of social media
star as an endorser how did that
relationship come about you know I was
introduced to DJ Collard by rock Nation
and spent quite a bit of time with him
and he really is authentic but what's
amazing about Weight Watchers is the
power of the community and with his goal
to really be healthier particularly for
his son Asad and inspire his community
along with him to lead healthier lives
does he want to lose weight he's already
lost about 20 pounds but for him it's
really more about being the best self he
can be and I think that's what people
want today it's not necessarily thinking
about diet it's thinking about
sustainable health and how you want to
live a better life which is the other
part of this right it's the holistic not
you're not just very nice on the entire
it's my body spirit it's a combination
of eating healthy having the right level
of activity and mindfulness plays a very
big part in how people are thinking of
health today so our move from being just
about weight to a more holistic approach
to giving people the tools to live a
healthier life across the board is
really very important it's starting with
beyond the scale freestyle is another
evolution and what you'll see from us
around behavior science and the agile
innovation and continuing to make it
simple around the power of our community
whether it's our connect community
whether it's our meetings and physical
whether it's the WW cruise that we just
had so think of a health and wellness
week on the sea so giving people tools
to holistically integrate into their
lives there are so many health wellness
weight-loss whatever you want to call it
options for consumers out there for
better or worse what is it about Weight
Watchers that you want to tell consumers
who are in the market that you offer
that others don't you know if you think
about it I mentioned before that our
biggest competition
people really thinking they can do this
themselves only 5% of people use a
traditional weight-loss program so we
want to address the 95 percent where we
can truly be their partner to give them
the tools and educate them on why they
can live healthier lives and our program
as you said it's number one globally for
sustainable weight loss and getting
people to understand that and have it be
part of their lives is really what we
want to accomplish what's black coffee
you have zero points you can even put a
little milk in if you'd like I've seen
I've seen Gail it's changed her now she
cheats just fruit the morning yeah
that's zero no it's fantastic thank you
so much thank you